the president hosted top commanders and
their partners last night at the White
House amid concerns about North Korea
and the Iran nuclear deal President
Trump made puzzling comments during the
gathering of military leaders
here's know what his represents
some say that sounds a little ominous
when asked again what he meant the
president responded quote you'll find
out the White House has not clarified
his comments mr. Trump faces an October
15th deadline on the Iran nuclear deal
he is expected to refuse to certify that
Iran is in compliance Margaret Brennan
is at the White House with more on that
story Margaret good morning good morning
well president Trump is not expected to
tear up the nuclear deal with Iran but
he will endanger it by having Congress
weigh in on whether to reimpose some
sanctions on Iran now doing so goes
against the advice of his top national
security advisors including secretaries
mattes and Tillerson who acknowledge
that Iran is living up to its promise to
freeze its nuclear program however the
president says Iran's breaking the
spirit of the deal and is expected not
to certify its compliance that's going
to allow lawmakers to run the risk of
putting the u.s. in violation of the
nuclear deal which would then threaten
to unravel the entire international
agreement now the Trump administration
hopes that threat plus new aggressive
steps against Iran will help launch a
new round of diplomacy Iran's president
Hassan rouhani has accused the White
House of simply seeking an excuse to
break the deal now remember here Alex
what happens next isn't just about the
US Russia China the UK France Germany
and the EU all signed this arms control
agreement and they have all purged the
president not to take this action
Margaret thanks